gotta be tough to be a lady a lot of
ways you know some perks ladies yeah I
think you're allowed to uh you're
allowed to announce your standards in
public I think men announce our
standards we look a lot shittier like I
was hanging out with some friends we're
all drinking talking about our type my
gay friend was like I like a muscular
guy like muscles on a man all right gay
guy muscles my lady friend was like I
got tall guy I told you yeah women like
tall guys so like what do you like Mark
I was like I like skinny girls with big
tits and then I went oh what a [__]
[__]
I was like well wait how come you're
allowed to shame me for what I'm
attracted to you guys are shallow I
cannot be shallow you say you like tall
guy I'm not a tall guy when you said I
wasn't like classic [__] over here
I'd rather be taller but that's my issue
I'm not going to yell at you she's like
well it's messed up he won't sleep with
certain women I'm like what about the
gay guy he won't [__] any women yell at
him